hello everyone uh I am Lis Spa I'm here
with Flav Brazil we work in a company
that has more than a thousand
microservices written en enclosure so
using the jvm and the service are
running in kubernetes
clusters unfortunately closure is not so
popular but jvm and kubernetes are
common to used by several companies and
it brings some challenge that we'll talk
today during this
presentation to start we'll talk a
little bit about new bank and the
payment Market in brail to give a better
understanding of the size of the problem
people in us know new bank mainly
because you we acquired cognitech the
company behind closure and atomic but
new bank is much more than it new bank
is a mobo first Finch found in
2013 uh in Brazil with the mission of
fight complexity and charging no fees
our first product was a cred car in 2014
and since then I we are seen uh hyper
growth in the number of customers and in
July of this year we reach we reach uh
85 million customers now we are also
operating in Mexico and
Colombia thank to this growth new bank
in 10 years went from a small startup to
the fourth biggest bank in Brazil
another Shing data is that 46% of uh
adult Brazilian population is a no Bank
customer now almost one in every two
people when you are in a hyper Growth
Company you are constantly challenged
with scaling issues and to make things
worth we had the perfect
storm in the end of
2020 uh the Brazilian Cal Brank launched
pigs PS is a real time 247 payment
platform you can use your PX key that
can be an email cell phone numers social
ID a random key or you can just scan a
QR code to transfer money and payments
instantly at any
time PX was a huge success in Brazil and
very a very fast adoption in July of
this year P reached almost 4 billion
transactions in 10
month and now p is essential for
people's dayto day like in Brazil people
don't say anymore make a payment people
say make a px so if a px is not working
it's a huge
problem and especially during thee Day
in Brazil in the beginning of each month
we are facing several instance with
Peaks it was make our customers unhappy
because they have money in their
checking accounts but they couldn't use
it so they were unhappy with reason and
it was also causing uh reputational
damage for us since even the Press was
talking about the problem also since
since new bank is one of is one of the
largest banks in Brazil when we are out
all the p p ecosystem suffers generating
also regulatory concerns from Brazilian
Central
Bank so uh thank you ESP to understand
the problem uh we decided to start
specting systems to understand where the
instability was coming from um the first
thing that we observed is what we call
the called the crash resolution Paradox
because a strange situation we would see
a system running for example for 3 days
here and even during the peak hours of
the day it would reach only 5% of the
CPU usage but then when we got to the
payday and the load Spike that came with
it we would see the system fading
because of CPU usage so the system would
go top 100% CPU usage and we would some
sometimes have to manually for example
restart the system um and the Laten is
would skyrockets and many systems would
become unresponsive and the resolution
for this kind of Crash was actually
increasing the CPU resources of the
system so it's a strange situation right
how come A system that can't use its CPU
Coda efficiently fail because of CPU
usage when there's a load Spike uh the
second observation was a couple crashes
that uh escalated to Cluster wide inst
stability uh in those crashes we saw
some nodes in kubernetes uh starting to
get saturated so basically they were
they didn't have enough CPU resources to
handle the workloads and threads were
killing in the schedu Linux
schedul uh in most of the cases we saw
that a few problematic systems were
consuming all CP resources of the nodes
and this pattern of instability spread
to multiple nodes so we got our whole
cluster actually in an unhealthy State
and several systems were fading in that
case and these are strange patterns
right these are strange symptoms uh and
they are actually symptoms of a
bottleneck uh the universal scalability
law explains that when you are
containing fire results when you have
the CPU for example at 100% there is a
natural degradation of the deficiency of
the system but then when you start
having effects of coherence that is
basically coordination between threats
for example for CPU throttling between
for quota uh there is normally a sharp
drop in efficiency uh that uh explains
what we were seeing with our systems um
and we were seeing also in the trends of
the metrix we had so the Blue Line there
is the CPU usage medium across the day
and the bars are the cost of the system
so the median CPU usage was dropping
over time and the cost was growing
higher than the loads that we had so
basically we had hit a bottleneck and
that bottleneck was making our systems
less efficient over
time so we set two main goals uh to
solve this problem uh the first one is
even if the systems get overloaded they
should remain functional they shouldn't
be fading because they can't handle the
loads and the second goal is that
problematic systems could not affect the
performance of other systems right so
these were the two things that we were
after when we started this uh
Journey well the path to our goals
wasn't trivial since there is a lot of
uh conflict information on the
internet when running several containers
inside the same machine Linux has some
mechanisms to guarantee the CP CPU
isolation to avoid that a container
interfer in all the others also in the
kubernetes word you can use the CPU
requests and CPU limits to Define how
much CPU a container can use the CPU
requests in kubernets becomes the CPU
shares configuration and the CPU limits
becomes the CPU
quter the CPU request acts as a soft
limit the container you use you have at
least that amount of CPU to use and the
CPU limit act as a hard limit that's the
maximum CPU that the container will be
allowed to
use CPU requests works with priorization
when all CPUs are busy while there is
free CPU in the node containers can use
more CPU than requested without
limitation only when our CPU are busy it
prioritize execution to guarantee that
each container use at least the CPU
requested on the other hand the CPU code
is enforced even if the node has more
CPU
available and the CPU request isn't able
to prevent no saturation as it only act
when containers are contained for CPU
CPU limits can in most of the cases
avoid saturation it's a quot and not a
concr limit but it's generally
enough this CPU quot mechanism can show
some weird scenarios in this case for
example we have a system that with a low
average CPU usage people can look at
this graph and even consider the system
is over provisioned and we don't expect
any CPU throttling it is casy when we
are talking about CPU throttling it's
the case like when Linux stop all the
threads of your application and you can
run anything during this
period and surprising you have CPU
throttling even if have very low average
CPU uh to understand why we need to
understand how CP throttling works so we
have this example it's a fictitious
example of a container having four cars
of Coda uh and we are Distributing the
CPU usage in these squares that are
basically 20 milliseconds of CPU usage
uh and we have a few periods in the
example the first one is basically the
application running with far threads or
far cores active throughout the that
period and it's basically within the
coda right so it's using it full Coda
there's no CPU throttling no problems uh
the second period actually the load goes
down and the application isn't able to
use the full CPU code and an important
factor here is that the CPU usage that's
the CPU code that's not used cannot be
reused later the application loses that
CPU F that wasn't used in the period uh
and then we get to the point that is
interesting that is the application has
a load Spike uh it starts using many
cars in parallel and then it consumes
the CPU Koda very quickly right so uh if
the application has too many threads
running it's going to basically consume
all the resources that's allocated to it
very quickly and at this point the CPU
is going to be throttled and with as has
plan mentioned when it's throttled it's
actually pausing the entire container
even things that are for example GC or
uh more lowlevel Linux
operations uh on the fourth period there
is an interesting pattern that we see
that is uh in the previous periods the
application was paused for a while so
you have some backlog of work to do
right so the application is going to
start processing that backlog and if it
doesn't have a good concurrency limit
it's going to consume all the quoda
again very quickly and then get
throttled again so it's something that
accumulates right it's a pattern that
introduces a lot of um issues into the
system and then for the last periods we
have like just the load going down and
then some throttling still uh it's very
important
to keep in mind that when the CPU
throttling happens it's pausing not only
for example the request handling HTTP
requests or and everything but it's also
pausing for example garbage collection
in the jvm it's pausing health checks
right so you can start having lots of
problems and that's a lot of the factors
that ended up producing stability in our
systems so it's clear that CPU throt CPU
throttling is a huge problem but how to
solve it how to avoid CPU throttling
there are currently too many uh current
schools of thought about this
problem first one is just disable limits
it's a common recommendation to avoid
setting the limits configuration and
allow syst to use the resources freely
until a node became saturated at with
point the CPU request will be enforced
the other is is CPU pinning is the one
through way some people recommend do not
use CPU requests and limits and allocate
specific CPUs to specific containers via
CPU
pinning but both these Solutions have
some limitations when disable limits for
example how can we prevent problematic
systems from consuming Alp research of a
node and affect performance of col Lo AT
Systems also reasoning about the
performance of systems can become very
challenged since it becomes uh
environment dependent a system might
behave well if the node has free CPU to
be used but it will perform poly in an
old with no CPU to
borrow CPU pinning also has some
important down sides what about small
systems with fractional quotas uh we
have a large number of Sy distance and
Men of 10 use very small quas sometimes
even less than a core so the lack ofal
qu when pining could H with pining could
increase the cost of all the kubernetes
Clusters also it it do not allow uh
there is no possibility of bursts and it
adds pressure to kubernetes scatterling
like the combination problem that pet
needs to to do to allocate pods to nodes
becomes much more complex when with the
additional CPU pining pining
Dimension but more importantly we felt
that these approaches weren't proper
answers for our problems the real
question is what are these approaches
hiding so this problem is actually
connected to a common problem in
software engineering that is the danger
of averages so almost a decade ago uh
guiltin published this blog post where
he has a definition of average that is
uh a random number that fall somewhere
between the maximum and half the median
most often used to ignore reality right
um and today in our industry we can say
that like when we show a graph like this
that is just an average of of latency
people already know this is not
something good this is not a good way of
measuring latency and today we use
percentiles for that right so we see the
distribution of latencies to understand
how the systems actually
behaving uh but then we go to how we CPU
usage again and if you pay attention
It's actually an
average so what's happening there we
have uh observability systems like
Prometheus for example uh doing scraping
of Matrix every interval for example one
minutes here that is a common interval
uh and what is it it scraping it's
basically three counters R CPU usage so
we have only a snapshot every minute of
the CPU usage so when we go back to that
example where we have low CPU usage with
CPU throttling can we really say that
the system is not hitting its Cod right
we have only a snapshot and an average
over minutes can the system maybe be
using more CPU than the resources during
that one minute window and we ask again
what is this H hiding right so the
actual thing is the CPU average is a lie
right it doesn't represent how the
system is using it CPU resources it
doesn't show for example these patterns
of variation that can generate CPU
throttling and today we have very low
visibility in our IND industry because
we use average for CPU utilization so to
solve that we decided to develop a new
solution that is basically uh having
fine grain CPU Matrix uh initially we
just build something very quickly with a
terminal dashboard there is this project
called sampler it's a great project to
build terminal dashboards and we
intergrated it with jmx to connect to a
pods and then observe the CPU usage in
real time so here you can can see that
what we were seeing before the far
percent is just a lie right this is the
actual behavior of the system sometimes
it has a load Spike on CPU sometimes
it's mostly idle sometimes there's a
spike where it sustains for a while so
this is really really interesting
information right this is valuable
information to optimize the systems uh
we eventually also started comining
these metrics uh in a histogram so we
basically measure every 100 milliseconds
and then we provide histogram from
perthus scrape every minute so we can
see how the CPU usage is varying within
each one minute window that's uh of the
scraping right and this gives like a lot
of visibility over the problem but then
the next big question is how can we make
systems behave what are the main factors
that make them vary the CPU usage uh and
our answer was creating a new solution
to control the concurrency of
applications we developed a solution to
automatically control the concurrence of
systems in a way that allows them to
avoid major degradation it's an Adaptive
threading model that constantly tun the
systems to avoid CPU
throttling we called our project navu
inspired by the tech Pense show and
there are three main things NAU
does first one finding gradient perfum
metics like you can you can't improve
what you don't measure so we added
several new meds like percentiles of CPU
usage percenti of throttling the time
delay to scedule threads a bunch of new
matrics that give us a better
understanding of what was happening with
the
systems the second is an Adaptive
concurrency no more manual thread no
more manual thread pool tuning it's
really hard to define the size of a
thread pool should have since it can
change a lot depend off the workload
like if you have a CPU intensive flow
the behavior will be completely
different of a flow with too much IO and
thread blocking that's why we believe
that an Adaptive concurrence solution is
important and the third point is
reactive pressure reject work above the
system's capacity with a unbounded if
you are in a system with a huge load
your C can grow very fast putting
pressure in the memory and in
the put putting pressure pressure in the
GC and the out out application
the first thing to navu Works uh navu
needs to control the
concurrency uh we try different approach
Implement to n controls the concurrency
it needs a mechanis to detect
degradation in a service we tried
different approach to implement this
detection mechanism our first try in
vzero was check all the things and what
does that
mean uh we are checking CPU usage CPU
throttle percentage memory everything
trying to avoid degradation after some
experiments we saw that this mechanism
was working well to control uh
instability but it was too strict as it
didn't accept any throttling and so it
was hurting the performance for some
systems then we added the heartbeat
mode this mode was inspired in the
inspired in the J C solution created by
gutin and basically it starts a new
thread that runs a while loop with a
sleep call inside it Force the scatter
to put or thread to to run immediately
after uh the sleep so we can measure
this time and we can identify delays in
the scatter which IND indicates
degradation the good part of this
solution is that it also detects GC paes
jvm safe points and also allocation
stles with this solution we had a better
performance results without compromising
stability that was our main
focus so then once we had these
mechanisms to observe uh the degradation
of scheduling we had we had to introduce
a way of controlling the concurrency of
the system so uh traditionally in a jvm
application we have executors using the
Linux CAD directly right so you are
starting threads and it's you are
scheduling those threads directly on the
Linux scheduler and we use the old
technique of introducing in Direction so
we added navo in the middle so executors
are redirected to navu and then we can
in navu control how much concurrency is
available to the system uh there is like
some complexity around how to redirect
those threat pools we are not going to
be able to go in details uh but how we
control the concurrency is actually very
simple um if you have the system having
degradation it means that it's hitting a
bottleneck so you have for example too
many threads and you are hitting C F
throttling or you have too many threads
you're processing and allocating too
much memory and you're having having
allocation installs rgc pauses right so
you are basically uh with by reducing
the concurrency you are redu na is
reducing the capacity of the system so
it can avoid any botle neck that might
be happening at that moment and it's
something that's happening all the time
so it's not something that we process
and then apply to systems it's something
that's running with the system all the
time to adapt to the workload uh and
then if the system has the thre being
scheduled reliably there is no
degradation uh then NAU allows the
system to use more concurrency uh if
necessary and for this mechanism we had
uh two main challenges the first one is
reaction time uh for example if you have
a system that's running and you have for
example uh GC execution that is going to
consume some CPU in parallel in
concurrently to the application is might
need to reduce the concurrency of the
application at that point right so um it
needs to be something that reacts fast
to these kind of change changes in
workloads or if you have thread blocking
and an external system has a higher
latency you have to quickly react to
allow more threads if necessary uh and
the other uh challenge is the stability
of the control Loop uh if you have a
control Loop that's always changing
threads all the time you can hurt the
performance of the system right so
because you are always introducing noise
in the execution and for these two
problems the first one we solved by
using uh something simple that is start
with small changes but if they are not
not effective it quickly escalates using
explanation steps so it adapts right
right quickly uh but in a stable manner
right uh the second solution was
basically for the control Loop to be
stable we introduced a meta stable state
that is that the control Loop attacks
that the application is close to its
limits but it's not degraded to a points
that we need to act so the control Loop
basically keeps the system as it is
without making changes so it reaches a
table points at that uh a certain uh
moment so here we have some examples uh
of workloads and navu adapt the number
of threads in this case navu is adapt
the number the number of threads to load
with low uh CPU usage and thread
blocking so as the load increases NAU
can also increase the number of threads
to avoid queuing and it's totally fine
because everything is under control like
there is no C throttling the uh the hard
be delay to get the uh delays in Scatter
is okay the CPU users is under control
so it's totally fine youu increase the
number of threads to be able to handle
the Lo that is increasing
too uh here in this case for example
it's not easy to see but now is already
with 200 threads and and it's totally
fine
in this another example nav is adapt the
number of threads to a CPU intensive
load so the threads needs to really use
the CPU so in this case navu needs to
decrease the number of threats because
we are we are the service is suffering
with CPU throttling and also there is
some delay to to scedule uh the
threats and also uh this an example
shows the other uh other thing that does
that's been rejecting the some of the
test that's arriving to this the service
so in this case 5% of the new tasks are
being rejected so NAU can maintain the
services table because the main focus
here is try to avoid uh this the service
crashes like if you if you if you had a
a hardcoded uh trading uh thread number
of threads uh if you try to use all
threads the service can crash so navu is
automatically adapting for it so in this
case for example navu is using uh 24
threads and another aspect that's very
important that uh the other things like
GC for example if there is a lot of
garbage in the application the GC
threads also use CPU and so navu is also
able to detect this increase of tasks uh
GC threads running and also reduce the
number of threads to avoid CPU
throttling and when JC is over navu can
increase the number of threads again
everything
automatically now we will show some
results uh we will show three cases with
three different impacts n have in the
service at new bank the first case is a
Improvement in the stability it's the
social service it's a service that is H
have um
it's a key service for the PX flow uh
and after navo adoption you can see a
significant Improvement in the service
stability like before the before the
stability was decreasing month after
month the service was suffering a lot
and we can see that now the the trend
reverted and the stability is increasing
now month after
month uh this the second case is is
amazing is the Improvement in in the
Laten of called
magnitude uh and this service was
suffering a lot with throttling before
navu because it was using too many
threads and so it was suffering with CPU
throttling after the NAU adoption and
the congruency control to avoid
degradation we saw a significant
Improvement in the
latency and the third case was an cost
reduction Improvement is in the Storm
Shield uh another key service for the
pig flow this service was was very
unstable before navu and to to try to
mitigate it the team increased the
service resources a lot after we added
NAU and made the service stable we could
remove the over provision of the service
without compromising the
stability now we'll talk a little bit
about the next steps post navoo adoption
and what are our plannings to the future
of to the future of the
project with NAU enabled in Serv at new
bank we can identify performance Boton X
more clearly to give an example of it uh
in this case uh using the CPU percenti
metric we identify PS in the PS in the
P99 CPU usage in a service and we
correlated it with some specific end
point calls with high
latencies looking the code we saw that
the points were using a closure Mark
production that should be used only in
development environments that were very
expensive so once the fix was deployed a
large drop in the P90 and P99 CPU usage
was
observed it's interesting that the
average CPU usage continue exactly the
same so without these new metrics navu
added we couldn't even measured the
Improvement uh this case was a mistake
of the engineer that uh Implement these
in points but like this mistake was in
productive for months into service
that's a very important service and only
when we added the navu we are able to
see it easily and fix it and there are
several case like this one with people
from other team sharing first that they
use navu to identify performance B
next so now that navu is rolled out to
most services and the critical ones at
new bank we are focusing on building the
next iteration of the project uh and we
have three main focuses uh the first one
one is lower overhead so we have system
that use have coders for example of half
a car uh and the metric collection and
the control Loop becomes too much
overhead for this kind of system so we
are focusing on buing solutions to avoid
these overheads and support this kind of
workloads uh the second focus is Loom
integration uh now is a key point where
we can easily switch executors from
native thread blocking to Virtual
threads uh so it's very convenient for
us to do uh to do the migration to
uh and something that's very important
sometimes there's some confusion because
people confuse the need for something
like navu versus green green threads
right uh it's actually these are
orthogonal problems even systems that
are fully as synchronous they benefit
from naus uh features for example we
have systems that are on top of closures
C syn and they still benefit from the
thread ping thread pool tuning and they
still benefit from for example the uh
load shedding when necessary and the
third focus is preparing for open source
we hoped maybe to have open source by
the event today but we couldn't but we
are focusing on building and preparing
for open source so feel keep an eye for
announcements from no no Banks
Engineering if you are
interested uh just to finalize before
finalizing we want to highlight
something very important so the work to
stabilize F and the new Banks platform
as a whole was like a collaboration of
multiple teams right so we have teams uh
rewriting systems we have teams
migrating to different databases we have
have like optimizations of our own
Atomic database so there's like lots of
work of many teams right and naul's
adoption was basically just one slice of
this work so it's not everything right
uh and now we have what we can say is
payday sanity so the system works when
we get to the payday we have to knock on
wood to say that right because it's hard
but uh it's really something that
changes how we uh the company is able to
focus on Building Solutions for the
users right instead of dealing with
systems problems so it's a really a
breakthrough for us in August for
example we had 99.9 availability for the
PX transactions that is really a huge
breakthrough for us so um that's all we
had for today uh we have our Traer
handles there if you want to check it
out and if you have any questions we are
going to be around feel free to reach
out and uh we are especially interested
interested if you're working in the same
domain the same kind of problems please
come talk to us so we can exchange
experiences as well so that's all thank
you
[Applause]
than